ja was geht hat sich über uns zu diesem
video ich habe ja wirklich jetzt in den
letzten tagen durch ware unter anderem
ziemlich für den neue abonnenten
gewonnen
ich dachte mir ich nehme das ganze mal
zum anlass einfach ein paar fragen zu
beantworten
das habe ich jetzt schon wirklich ewig
nicht mehr gemacht früher habe ich das
voll häufig gemacht und ja auch toll da
konnte ich mehr fragen stellen
falls ihr mir da folgen wollt allerdings
den vier mal der beschreibung und ich
würde sagen wir legen einfach direkt mal
los fragend numero uno und nicht nur
dort wirst du dein eigenes murchison
also ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall
nicht mehr vor weihnachten was raus
bringen das wäre wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen zu spontan an sich hätte ich
doch wahrscheinlich bock drauf weil
wörtlich eigentlich eine coole sache um
sich irgendwie auszudrücken man sich
auch so zu verbinden mit der community
sage ich meinen aber ja also ich glaube
ich habe da selbst einen extrem hohen
anspruch an mich selbst und sobald ich
mit coole idee habe werde ich die
definitiv umsetzen
auf einer skala von eins bis zehn wie
sehr ich dich lukas war wo vier torleute
war u4 luca minister morgen auch bei
diesem frage antwort ding wurde alles
damit überhäuft wie sehr mich der tod
traders ich meine ich habe ich vor damit
abgefunden
es ist ja alles in ordnung gewesen wie
ich auch einmal eigenen video auf betont
habe und von daher auf einer skala von 1
bis 10 3 weil ich jetzt halt alleine mit
330 die bessere 33 passen darf nun auch
die letzte frage die ich jetzt für den
ganzen fahrzeugs beantwortete später
kommen noch eine folge waren könnt ihr
auf jeden fall aus checken wie stehst du
zu der ganzen war ursache von contra
vermisster morgen wie luca auch in
seinem entschuldigungs video gesagt hat
haben wir uns darüber schon unterhalten
ich persönlich fand den beigeschmack den
das statement video hatte nicht gut also
das ist ja jetzt nichts was man nicht
sagen gab oder sowas als freuen sondern
im gegenteil ich meinen
ich habe mich halt auch gesagt das ist
nicht so so ganz sauber
die sache ist luca hat jetzt seinen
fehler eingesehen klar so manch man sagt
immer gezogene reichweite kannst du dir
sowas nicht erlauben
man muss schon überlegt handeln aber
wenn man mal einen fehler macht dann
sollte man sich auch dafür entschuldigen
dürfen und es sollte auch ankommen
insbesondere wo minister morgan und
lukas sich jetzt auch persönlich
unterhalten haben und anscheinend alles
wieder geklärt ist bei den beiden
runtergebrochen mein standpunkt luca
betti fehler gemacht aber er hat sich
jetzt auch wirklich mühe gegeben das
ganze wieder gutzumachen nie drin fragt
war war wo ein anspruch wieder minecraft
konnte zu bringen oder ist danach
schluss damit also für mich war das
definitiv ein ansporn also ich habe echt
spaß daran gehabt und aus diesem grund
haben wir auch jetzt uns entschieden
minecraft 1 zu launchen also dass
minecraft projekt was am 22 dezember
beginnt davon gibt es dann erstmal nur
zehn folgen weil was mich und glaube ich
auch luca bei minecraft ein bisschen
gestört ist dass es sich so viel
wiederholt und deshalb haben wir das
auch limitiert einfach weil wir finden
am meisten spaß macht wenn man es
einfach ein bisschen begrenzt und
deshalb machen wir erstmal minecraft
marx was danach passiert wird man dann
sehen wie viele jahre differenz haben du
und escape mein bruder ist ziemlich
genau eineinhalb jahre älter als ich was
sind deine ziele 2017 innerhalb und
außerhalb von youtube also ich ziehe zum
15 januar nach köln minderheit in der
nähe von allen youtuber und so weiter
und so fort als meine ziele auf youtube
sind definitiv mehr videos ja auch
einfach viel spaß dabei zu haben dass
ich jetzt wirklich vielen anderen
youtuber irgendwie zusammen arbeiten
kann und coole videos machen kann
außerhalb von youtube auf ja mal dass
ich gesund bleibe dass sie vielleicht
ein studium finde was ich gehen möchte
und was mich interessiert und dass viel
mehr will ich eigentlich gar nicht
sollte
hört ihr das auch im hintergrund ich
glaube ich gewässer mal nachschauen
[Musik]
ihr fragt euch bestimmt warum ich hier
sitze und alles so weihnachtlich ist das
hängt damit zusammen dass die telekom
mit angehoben hat ihr seht
wahrscheinlich schon hier irgendwie
werbevideo oder sowas stehen aber ich
habe ich sagen dass es echt coole sache
ist sowohl für mich als auch für euch
und zwar kennt ihr vielleicht das video
von telekom zum magischen
adventskalender
das ist ziemlich riesig also es hat
irgendwie schon neun millionen aufrufe
oder so und ich finde persönlich dass es
auch wirklich schön gemacht ist also es
kommen vor die weihnachtliche gefühle
auch wenn man das so sieht war sie die
geschichte von einem kleinen jungen der
einen magischen adventskalender findet
und probiert die türen zu öffnen aber es
scheint einfach nicht zu funktionieren
und wie es dann letztendlich
funktioniert und was auch das schöne ist
an dem ganzen ist dass er die türen nur
öffnen kann wenn er sie mit jemandem
teil
und ja die message ist einfach ziemlich
schön finde ich weil darum geht hier
auch in der weihnachtszeit dass man
miteinander teilt und sich sachen
schenkt um halt nicht nur auch was
besseres zurück zu bekommen sondern auch
einfach mal irgendwie schön und ja weil
ich einfach glücklich hinter der message
stehe eine super cool dass telekom mit
dafür an grauen hat die ganze kampagne
läuft nämlich auch unter dem hashtag
teilen verbindet warum das ganze auch
cool für euch ist ist ganz einfach für
uns nimmt der kunde teil ihr könnt diese
geschichte von dem kleinen jungen mit
dem magischen adventskalender selbst
hören und zwar tag für tag es ist
sozusagen so ein eigener adventskalender
und darf zu sind allerdings in der
beschreibung
falls ihr lust habt die geschichte im
adventskalender zu hören verlinkt ich
halte uns einmal alles und dann würde
ich sagen langsam verschwindet der
weihnachtliche max und die beine
[Musik]
so leute hat er einen werbe unter dem
rechnung machen wir mal weiter
ich fand aber wirklich die ich auch
gesagt habe dass das nur kampagne war
und deshalb habe ich mitgemacht so ich
hab jetzt mir noch mal extra
weihnachtliche fragen stellen lassen um
das feeling aufrecht zu erhalten sagt
nein und zwar wurde ich gefragt
zuckerwatte oder glühwein bis beide sich
so mein
ein all time favorite also zuckerwatte
finde ich jetzt immer so enttäuschend
weil zuckerwatte sie zum mega cool aus
und dann bei stuhlreihen und plötzlich
ist es noch so wenig wisst ihr aber
glühwein ja ich denke mal ich mitnehmen
was wünscht du dir zu weihnachten wie
gesagt sich an 15 jahren meine erste
wohnung ein und ich denke mal weiter so
aufregend wie es ist wir irgendwelche
sachen für die wohnung wünschen
wie sieht das perfekte weihnachtsfest
berlin aus also am schönsten ist es
eigentlich so wie ich schon immer hatte
sage ich mal
also einfach diese routine kirche ich
finde das gehört dazu jetzt gar nicht
mal so megamäßig gläubig aber irgendwie
gehört das dazu also eine kirche dann
ein richtig gutes weihnachtsessen und
danach eine bescherung und den ganzen
abend zusammen verbringen spielen oder
sonst was gehst du gerne auf
weihnachtsmärkte ja ich gehe ziemlich
gerne auf weihnachtsmärkte einfach weil
das essen zugegebenermaßen ziemlich gut
ist weil weihnachtsessen irgendwie so
das leckerste essen mit was ich kenne
also ich bin wirklich die weihnachtszeit
zu wissen einfach so gut meint allein
ziehen so demmer aber ja ich gehe gerne
auf weihnachtsmärkten dort esse ich dann
und ich freue mich weil es so schön
aussieht weil einfach diese ganzen
lichter im winter auch ziemlich schön
aussehen
so leute ich würde mich auch schon
wieder von euch verabschieden wir sehen
uns auf jeden fall noch mal beim zweiten
video heute und das war erstmal macht's
gut und bis zum nächsten mal